want to bring Senator Lindsey Graham
into all of this senator of course
confidant of the president as well
senator what is your sense you're
getting from the White House and from
many of your colleagues about how this
is sorting out or not sorting out go big
the bottom line is I've been on the hill
all day I haven't seen this kind of
spirit since 9/11 everybody's looking at
each other as a ally not a foe people in
America you begin to see the best of the
country the young lady on the show
before delivering food to elderly people
allowing seniors to shop ahead of
everybody else in grocery stores it's
going to take that kind of spirit to
defeat this but here's the problem
80 percent of the workforce is going to
be impacted by the containment policies
the money we're spending to deal with
health care is going to pale in
comparison with the money we spend to
stabilize the economy if you've been
laid off today in South Carolina from a
bar or a restaurant or a hotel I'm
looking to make sure that we have wage
replacement that we replace your income
as much as possible so that you don't
have your life turned upside down that's
the number one goal of Phase three for
me so senator on obviously money in
people's hands is always a good thing
especially for the people who need it
but is it your sense that the problem
here is the virus itself and that people
were hunkered down in their homes afraid
to go because of this they might they
might use that in other means and pay
bills I get that but that it won't have
the desired effect on the economy or is
that even part of the rationale here
well it's my rationale I want to
stimulate the economy but it's
impossible to stimulate it when it's
locked down if I gave you your paycheck
that would be enough to get you through
until we can find a way to fully deal
with the virus your paycheck plus $1,000
doesn't do you any good
instead of getting a government check I
want you to get your paycheck as much as
possible it's like here's wonder though
it just drags on a while though that
people are going to be frozen
place regardless of what stimulus is
coming their way Oh DEP you can't
stimulate it
we're buying containment everything I've
just talked talk to you about it's the
price of containment shutting every bar
and restaurant down in South Carolina is
the cost of containment we either pay
now as a country or we pay later and
what do we do until we turn the corner
and what would turning the corner look
like